this is the seago 800s premium commuter
e-bike sent to us and sponsored by 10
ways and it's hands down the most smooth
and comfortable e-bike that I've ever
tried for five main reasons which I'm
gonna walk you through in this video and
I'm convinced that this is honestly the
perfect commuter e-bike especially for
urban environments now getting into the
bike itself this thing is built all
around for Comfort it's also built very
very well with really good build quality
being very solid sleek and premium now
before I get into the five main reasons
why this is the most comfortable
commuter e-bike I've ever tried I want
to go through a couple of the other
features where's the one I want to point
out is the LCD display that's actually
integrated into the frame as you can see
right here it's very easy to cycle
through nice and simple to use and this
also has pin code security so that way
if you don't put in the PIN code the
motor will not in gauge at all it's also
got lights on the front and the back and
this actually has integrated turn
signals which you can turn on so it's
very very useful for commuting home
after work at night now one thing that
looks really clean is the integrated
battery pack right here which looks
almost like stealthy built in you can
barely even notice it compared to others
where they have this massive battery
pack on it so it's actually portable
removable take it off bring it into your
office charge it up it's nice and safe
there's also this storage rack that's
built in right here so you can tie some
things down as well as this paneer bag
which comes optionally if you want to
get it and this thing actually unfolds
like this as you can see so you can fit
some pretty large items right here and
this bike also comes with a nice two
year warranty and my favorite feature is
actually the 10 Ways app where you can
connect this bike and kind of monitor
the miles per hour all of your data for
all of your trips your battery life and
everything so it's integrated and now
let's get into those five reasons for
ultimate comfort and smoothness starting
with the upright seating position as you
can see here it's very very comfortable
to use for long rides commutes the seat
is very nice large comfortable I
especially love these leather wrapped
handlebars right here basically the most
comfortable ones that I've ever used
with this stitching right in the back
number two is the front fork suspension
which is adjustable works very well also
we have the 20 inch puncture resistant
road tires which add to the reliability
and comfort and it also comes with this
really cool portable pump that you could
just simply slip into the paneer bag if
you ever need it and it has these really
really nice hydraulic brakes which I'll
show you in a minute number three is the
gates carbon belt drive which is
incredibly smooth to ride with basically
no chain that shakes or rattles or
requires tightening cleaning greasing
it's extremely reliable and 10 ways
guarantees a maintenance free ride for
over 18
000 miles for number four we have the
350 watt motor which is very smooth
because it uses the magnetic torque
sensor so it kicks in very smoothly it
doesn't just Jam in like crazy really
fast like other e-bikes very very smooth
almost a nice natural feeling and for
number five this is very lightweight for
the size of this e-bike as you can see
it's really nice and easy very smooth
comfortable to use convenient especially
the portable battery pack which is also
convenient to grab with you so I decided
to do exactly that this morning with
this e-bike to see how the daily commute
to work would be with the c8800s so the
nice thing about this bike is that it's
basically a Commuter so take it work
what's really unique about this bike is
that it's very easy to ride very smooth
I really love the Bell Drive because it
makes it so quiet fact that this thing
has hydraulic brakes makes it super nice
let's test them
yeah another nice thing is these shocks
they absorb a lot of the vibrations
bumps
everything super smooth like
look at that so nice and smooth and I
love how the batteries are integrated
right here and it's also nice that it's
a torque sensor so
when you're riding
it isn't just blast off like crazy
just like that take it right into your
office so with all that said I've got to
say that the 10 ways
c8800s is the perfect commuter bike all
around with all of the reliability the
smoothness the Comfort especially with
the carbon Gates belt drive making it
feel very smooth and on top of all of
that you also have the app which
basically wraps it up and integrates it
all for your commute so I've got to say
this is an awesome awesome Commuter
e-bike so let me know your thoughts on
it down in the comment section below and
click the circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
foreign